salut la tim hortons ça fait quelques
semaines que je vous avais demandé sur
facebook de m'envoyer tous vos my maps
pour en faire une vidéo quelques
semaines
donc j'ai eu du retard dans
l'organisation de mon me top qui se
passe cet après midi au youtube space et
là je me suis dit avant le mythe up tu
fais la vidéo donc j'ai reçu plein de my
maps différents tous intéressants il y
en a qui étaient complètement barré et
d'autres très utile j'en ai sélectionné
une petite quinzaine et on va les
regarder ensemble ils sont rangés par
ordre alphabétique dont le clézio
voisard et celui de braine le floch
donc c'est les pseudos facebook j'ai
trouvé très intéressant celui ci parce
qu'on a bien l'élément central de départ
on peut identifier facilement les sept
flèches je pense que je les aurais mis
en valeur avec des couleurs différentes
et c'est très synthétique c'est tout à
fait le but est surtout on a des
éléments clés autour et c'est ça dont on
va se rappeler le cerveau celui de
caroline a aussi est intéressant parce
que celui de caroline à elle s'en sert
lamy dans le message facebook comme
d'une espèce de tram à suivre pour
pouvoir en un seul coup d'oeil savoir où
elle en est et voir une arborescence
dans un fil conducteur d'entretien de
coaching et c'est vrai que j'avais pas
trop parler de cette option là mais on
peut s'en servir également pour faire
des fils conducteurs de rendez-vous de
conversation de discours pour le coup un
discours de l'abbé ça n'a aucun intérêt
par contre si on veut un discours vivant
mais sans oublier des points clés à
aborder ça c'est très bien suite
caroline je l'avait sélectionné aussi
parce que voilà on sait que c'est pas un
intérêt de chose à retenir c'est juste
un truc de synthèse qu'elle s'est fait
n'empêche que très visuellement
en quelques secondes on sait exactement
ce qu'elle aime un mets préférés c'est
celui de charlotte
alors même si effectivement c'est pas
forcément le plus créatif le plus coloré
il est parfait il est parfait parce
qu'on a le spleen au milieu et après on
retrouve les éléments clés dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure la saleté ou à la
celi la feuille la mort a éclaté de mort
la maladie avec la pharmacie le temps
qui passe directement le sablier et ça
pour synthétiser les informations et sur
une fiche de travail c'est juste parfait
de lucas barreau là on était plus sûr
sur un esprit pierre cros siens pourquoi
j'ai fait ce my maps
parce que je sais pas quoi faire parce
que je m'ennuie en cours de français bat
d'ailleurs suis un petit peu parce que
tu verras qu'il ya un truc à corriger
parce que je suis au dernier rang avec
la prof ne voit pas à oui juste à côté
il ya ludivine qui s'est déchirée sur un
my maps spéciale
koh lanta ça c'est du saas et du très
bon my maps aller à la limite le seul
truc met un peu plus en valeur les mots
quand même si c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit apprendre retire mais c'est très
très clairement pour un vol en avait
aussi envoyé un deuxième sur les sources
de la croissance économique
je suis patient qui vous amuse autant
match and alors là je vous laisse le
regarder et vous devez deviner ce que
c'est à quoi ça sert donc on a un zoo au
milieu tout autant on a des animaux qui
font une action précise
à quoi peut servir ce my maps il sert à
des élèves de maternelle leurs
enseignants et les enfants de maternelle
ont décidé ensemble de ce qu'il ne
fallait pas faire dans une classe en
rappel et s'en fait un espèce de my maps
comme ça pour enfants quand je vous
disais qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour
utiliser ça on est dans l'exemple
concret on a reçu de la part de manon la
fameuse réplication procar vote qui qui
va sauver le monde dans quelques années
on suppose en tout cas tout est là et
vous pouvez dire j'y étais je les ai vus
raishû raishû j'espère que je prononce
bien raishû sur toutes les étapes ou du
moins tout ce qui à définir pour écrire
un roman un roman fantastique
ça aussi c'est une bonne utilisation du
my maps pour avoir une vision globale de
ce qu'on a à faire et en même temps
c'est un espèce de brainstorming puisque
tout en faisant le map
on va identifier les choses à faire et
raisons pas forcément un ordre précis
c'est ça qui est essentiel on peut pas
se dire qu'il faut tout de suite penser
au personnage
ou alors d'abord aux lieux c'est un
mélange de tout ça en fait d'écrire un
roman donc le my maps est très adapté à
faire ça sarah boudreau et un petit my
maps que j'affectionne parce que oui je
suis très geek
alors forcément ça me plait moi de voir
ça a dû et du où tous les systèmes
logiques
celui ci s'est sixtine de passe celui ci
c'est sixtine c'est pas si facile à dire
celui-ci ses boucles je n'arriverais pas
leur dire de voir celui-ci s'est sixtine
qu'il l'a envoyée on voit pas très bien
malheureusement ça aussi c'est une très
bonne utilisation du my maps parce que
c'est la synthèse de tout le poème
qu'elle a appris par coeur de lewis
carroll est juste en suivant les dessins
à partir du 1 comme ça et en tournant il
va être capable de se rappeler des
éléments et donc des phrases à prononcer
et c'est très très très très malin
d'avoir fait sa vie qui a fait un
superman maps sur le vegan et qui c'est
qui nous a fait du speed painting à la
fin ça pourrait presque y est une
synthèse de compte
france alors en m durand ou en changeant
de trois trucs mais pour défendre le
projet vegan c'est super elle en avait
envoyé un autre beaucoup plus chelou mot
concernant toujours dans le style j'ai
un projet je cherche à le définir ya
celui du viol est alors on est sur un
trip survivre sur mars mais là aussi
mine de rien pour faire la vanne de
faire le manioc de vivre sur mars
on voit tout à fait le brainstorming qui
s'est mis en place il ya déjà une
arborescence est déjà quelque chose de
très logique donc on est plus sur une
carte heuristique que sur un my maps
la différence c'est cesser les couleurs
de ces dans la construction mais c'est
très utile quand même la preuve celui de
clément morin est aussi intéressant dans
une autre utilisation
il s'en est servi pour voir les
avantages les inconvénients des quatre
future qui se dessine pour lui et qui
voudraient choisir toi ça clément
c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais
pensé à faire utiliser le my maps pour
faire une prise de décision avec les
inconvénients et avantages donc je vais
clairement de voler l'idée pour
l'appliquer moi même à mes prises de
décisions certaines parce qu'au final
c'est très clair merci beaucoup de me
les avons envoyés d'avoir joué le jeu ça
m'a permis alors j'ai pas pu toutes les
passes et évidemment mais de faire voir
à tout le monde un panel de ce qu'on
pouvait faire via le my maps et les
cartes heuristiques j'étais ravi déjà de
voir que vous vous serviez de cet outil
là maintenant depuis je vous les fait
découvrir ça ça me fait toujours
tellement plaisir et grâce à vous et
tout ce que vous m'avez envoyé ça m'a
permis dans cette vidéo de faire voir
aux autres toutes les formes
d'utilisation possible et que ça sert à
rien des grands dessinateurs et nakiele
dessinée très bien il y en a qui
dessinent et pas du tout et c'est pas
gênant ça n'empêche pas de le faire est
d'utiliser sa merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous aura plu on continuera à faire
de didot ensemble là j'ai refait que
j'ai refait des true story et on a
refait des vidéos ensemble seront fait
une vidéo avec akinator je pense que la
prochaine étape c'est refaire une vidéo
où je vous mentalise l'un d'entre vous
voulu notre groupe par skype
je vous tiens au courant de ça si cette
vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez le faire
savoir
pas la peine de faire un my mac je suis
sûr que cette image mentale vous parle
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir moi je file à mon
meetup cet après midi je vous raconterai
ça sur la chaîne bien sûr vous le dis
pas souvent mais pensez à partager cette
vidéo ou des vidéos comme ça sur la
mémoire ou quoi ça ça peut être vraiment
utile à d'autres personnes donc autant
en profiter et je vous dis rendez vous
demain à 17 heures ciao